I don't want to set the world on fire I
just want to start a flame in you
it's been ten years since bethesda game
studios revived the beloved Fallout
franchise with fallout three well not a
perfect game at the time of its release
fallout 3 was a massive hit with both
critics and players introducing a much
larger audience to the post-apocalyptic
world
I myself was one of those people and I
have a sentence gone back and played
fallout 1 and 2 and have been a huge fan
of the franchise sense but in the decade
that's followed the reputations of both
fallout and Bethesda have been called
into question and with the recently
released fall 76 are on shaky er ground
than ever now a lot of criticism toward
76 can be attributed to that games
specific designs and it's multiplayer
focus but this general disappointment
isn't new it's followed the franchise
for years this can be attributed to
multiple factors old fans have long
criticized how Bethesda handles the tone
of the series using the iconography
while lacking the sarcastic black humor
that properly contextualized it it's
also feeling that pathetic writing just
isn't as sharp as past games and of
course there is some that are probably
just fed up with the infamously broken
state these games are launched in
despite my continued love for these
games I do agree with a lot of these
criticisms but it's also really easy to
find videos on the internet about all
this going into exhaustive detail of how
everything Bethesda has done wrong so I
wanted to do something different and
play devil's advocate after all there is
a reason people like Bethesda games and
there's a reason that fallout 3 was so
popular when it came out so I decided to
replay all the Fallout games recently
and see if I could find what exactly
Bethesda has brought to the series is
contributed to it and not only have I
come to the conclusion of what I think
the des des has brought to the series
but what I think Bethesda does uniquely
as a Western RPG studio
[Music]
okay so a great way to do all this would
be to compare fallout 3 to follow New
Vegas they're often compared to each
other being on the same architecture and
only a few years apart new Vegas is
generally considered by the vocal fans
to be the superior game with better
writing and world building after all its
developer obsidian entertainment is made
of former black aisle members the people
responsible for the original fallouts
and while I agree there are a lot of
things New Vegas does better replaying
them has made me realize how these games
have very different priorities when it
comes to their designs and their goals
let's look at the two studios but that's
the game studios and obsidian
entertainment obsidian comes from a
background of game design of what we
typically think of when we think of
Western RPGs games with a focus on
dialogue based storytelling and
decision-making dialogue with NPCs acts
as the primary means of how the player
interacts with the story and expresses
themselves while going along a carefully
laid-out path you can see this style of
RPG from other old-school Studios like
Bioware or even more modern Studios that
were inspired by them like CD Projekt
RED with The Witcher series the original
Fallout games fit into this design as
well
most of the games real meat is told to
you through text and dialogue partly due
to the limitations of the tech at the
time
Bethesda however has never followed this
lineage their games are more like
dungeon crawlers with little focus on
dialogue and more about the player
exploring a space and interacting with
it the first two Elder Scroll games
arena and dagger fall are all about long
dungeons combat and gameplay systems
that are meant to make it feel like a
real living world you don't have long
conversations with NPC's in these games
instead they are there to populate towns
and provide basic information that leads
you to the next quest it's about how you
explore a dungeon came across a bunch of
skeletons and nearly escaped death this
kind of focus puts Bethesda more in
common with immersive Sims like Ultima
Underworld or Deus Ex
as Bethesda games have become more
advanced in the area's dialogue has
become more important but the focus has
always been about creating these
realistic worlds for the player to
interact with so when Bethesda got their
hands on Fallout they made fallout 3 a
Bethesda style take on Fallout a game
where the focus is less about long
dialogue trees and more about creating a
world you believe in inhabit
NPCs don't just stand in place waiting
for you they have schedules and interact
with each other out in the wasteland
caravans the traders move from
settlement to settlement creatures
sometimes kill important characters
there's just enough unscripted elements
to the whole thing that even ten years
later I was still experiencing new
things I've never seen before and
fallout what a - it's the writing that
makes the world come to life in Fallout
3 the world itself just feels alive of
course fallout 3 isn't just a wasteland
simulation it does have curated quests
and a story to it but even the way
Bethesda lays this all out is very
different if you play new vegas the map
is designed around the main story you
start in Goodsprings and then are meant
to follow the road down south and make
one giant circle until you reach new
vegas at which point you start to get
more specific about which faction you
want to side with and then you kind of
branch off from there following the main
story intentionally leads you around the
whole map in a circle and you end up
visiting almost every major location in
the game the majority of side quests are
also placed along this path so that the
player has the opportunity to do them if
they want again it's a style of design
you can see in for example older Bioware
games and it works really well because
it's designed to make sure you the
player doesn't miss anything
fallout3 works completely different
following the main story only has you
traveling the South half of the map and
its layout is much more open-ended than
New Vegas --is this leaves almost all of
the north side of the map untouched a
player that only follows the main story
will never interact with major side
quests like head of a stage or visit
locations like the Republic of Dave or
for Constantine even significant
locations on the south side of the map
are easy to miss like the ghoul city of
underworld so while New Vegas uses its
main story as a way to drive the player
towards its content fallout three dozens
it's simply another part of the game
instead but that's - puts the onus on
the player to explore and discover
things for themselves the game
encourages this as much as possible and
PCs tell you of rumors about far-off
locations and the disk jockey 3 dog is
always hinting at new opportunities for
you to uncover and this is a key part of
what makes fallout 3 unique to pass
games it's a truly open-ended wasteland
and pathetic is more interested in
letting the player have the freedom and
opportunity to discover the world for
themselves you are rewarded for running
off in a random direction with the
discovery of new locations unique items
at the end of dungeons or an interesting
small story told through the environment
and computer terminals that
environmental storytelling is another
thing that Bethesda is really good at
some of the best stories in this game
are never actually told through spoken
dialogue but through terminals notes and
just honestly the way a room is laid out
skeletons embracing each other in beds
before they die or notes left behind by
lost family members of course New Vegas
has great stuff like this
- but fallout 3 is the one who brought
this to the series and I always feel
like it's these types of stories where
Bethesda's writing really shines so I
guess what I'm trying to say with all
this is that I don't think it's as
objective as people make it out to be
when comparing these two games these two
games are just designed very differently
because so many Western RPGs are
typically built around their writing I
think we default to that as one of the
main measurements of quality for the
genre
and to be fair this is what the original
fallouts are known for so that
expectation makes sense but if you the
player put more value on exploration on
building a world that encourages two
player curiosity and letting them tell
their own stories
I think fallout 3 has new Vegas beat in
that regards of course that's not to say
that these are mutually exclusive game
designs you could totally have a game
that combines the level of storytelling
and writing of New Vegas with fallout
threes exploration and player expression
through gameplay in fact that kind of
sounds like my dream fallout game a
perfect mix of the two and in many ways
that is what Bethesda try to do with
fallout 4 that game story uses a faction
system not unlike new vegas a--'s and
attempts to make your decisions count
with a branching narrative that the Fest
is never really done before
unfortunately it doesn't really work out
in both the scripted narrative and the
exploration end of suffering as a result
this is because all the world's
interesting content though really good
stuff is tied to the factions you don't
get access to that stuff unless you
engage in the main story and even and it
doesn't really get good until halfway
through but the game's world is still
designed like fallout 3 and Fallout 4 is
new junk as crafting material system
encourages you to get out and explore so
if you try and play the game like
fallout 3 you won't get a constant
stream of interesting quest to explore
on your own because they're all tied to
the main story fallout 3's main story
may feel divorced from everything else
but they never harmed one another here
they try and merge the two but both end
up suffering so you're probably
wondering can Bethesda do it do they
have the ability to successfully combine
their amazing exploration design with a
really good main story in sharp writing
the answer to that is yes because
they've actually already done it Far
Harbor is one of two major expansions
for Fallout 4 and it is everything I
want any pathetic Fallout game the foggy
island you explore is densely packed
with mystery things to discover hidden
quests and story quests I think it has
some of the best most interesting
writing that any pathetic game has ever
had almost every NPC has a quest for you
all of these quests feel well written
and put together the main narrative even
ends up feeding it to the mysterious
setting of the island connecting
everything together
going out explore on your own you'll
find tons of hidden quests environmental
storytelling new monsters it really has
everything
I want as in the side I also think the
writing is really damn good like on par
with New Vegas good are you soon how
would I even know I'm afraid if you're
looking for some biological test we can
do there isn't any
none that aren't fatal instead you have
to look for the sides holes in someone's
memory feelings of unexplained isolation
dreams but ultimately you have to decide
for yourself what do you believe have
you ever questioned your humanity I
think for Harper is that Follette
experience that a lot of people have
been looking for proof that Bethesda can
write a good story and still knows how
to create compelling quests while
retaining the player exploration that
they're known for it's hard to say how
this all came together so well maybe
they learn from the mistakes with the
main game or perhaps the smaller scope
forced them to focus on what was
important or maybe they didn't have to
worry about testing new features and
mechanics and could just refine what
they already had whatever the reason is
it works it's just a shame that because
it's DLC for a game that got a mixed
reception I don't really hear anyone
talk about it
which now brings us to 2018 and fallout
76 a multiplayer spin-off game that uses
the framework of Fallout 4
but fills it with other real players in
the mountain countryside of West
Virginia it feels like I've just
scratched the surface having put around
15 or so hours into the game but I'm
already seeing a lot of the greater
structure of the game and in many ways
it's the perfect example of possessed of
strengths and weaknesses with the
Fallout series for one I think West
Virginia is Bethesda's best map to date
it's designed like a theme park broken
up into different unique sections with
massive landmarks to explore and
discover
despite the rough aspects of an aging
engine the artistic side of fallout 76
is beautiful and compels me to keep
exploring and see what awaits along the
next hill exploring an overgrowth
countryside climbing up the top of a
mountain to a massive ski resort
visiting these sunken ruins of the
Capitol building I always feel like
there's something really interesting to
find around every corner and that's
always been to me what makes a really
good pathetic game now despite it being
multiplayer the map is so large that I
don't run into people that often playing
by myself captures those same feelings
of exploring I ruined wasteland I felt
with fallout 3 in fact with no NPC's
outside of the occasional robot it feels
more lonely just you in this beautiful
ruined wasteland and that's a pretty
unique story for a Fallout game we've
never really gotten something like that
unfortunately I do think not having any
NPCs also comes with a lot of
concessions without any people the
simulation of a real world the
combinations of systems and AI that
Bethesda originally brought to Fallout
is non-existent in fallout 76 people
don't walk around with schedules you
can't trick NPCs to murder them anything
like that that theme-park design I was
talking about becomes much more literal
as a robot stand in place waiting for
you to arrive so they can feed you the
next objective their well-written funny
robots but their robots
the type of quests and stories that can
be told are also more limited done only
through audio Diaries terminals and
scraps of paper
it's that same great environmental
storytelling that started with fallout 3
there's also really good environmental
stories in this game and great writing
however that's all there is there's no
NPC dialogue to balance it out so it's
just more terminals more audio logs more
writing and that's kind of when I
realized to make a truly great fallout
game I think there needs to be a balance
between player exploration and developer
crafted storytelling Bethesda excels at
the former creating worlds and systems
for players to create their own
narrative they're also great at using
the environment to tell their own
narrative and less traditional means
what they aren't as good at is the
latter with more traditional
characterization and weaving a
well-written narrative like obsidian did
with Fallout New Vegas but that's okay
they had just enough they're in games
like fallout 3 that it works
fallout 76 leans too much on player
exploration and lacks that driving
narrative story and narrative may have
never been Bethesda strength but is an
essential component that is needed to
hold their game experiences together and
yet while fall at 76 may disappoint in
that regards along with other issues
that are honestly a whole separate video
considering that it's a multiplayer
spin-off that's trying something new I
can't really find myself seeing it as a
sign of Bethesda's fall from grace as a
developer I still think they have the
talent to provide the Fallout experience
a lot of people are looking for far
harbor's proof of that with their next
projects being the brand new IP star
field and the long-awaited Elder Scrolls
6 we probably won't see a proper fallout
5 for a long time and honestly I'm
completely ok with that
Bethesda should take a break from
fallout try new stuff and recharge with
their creative batteries so when they
finally do return to post-apocalyptic
America it can feel just as fresh as it
did 10 years ago
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]